collier de la marche économiste membre
fondateur d econoclaste et experts dans
l'émission c'est cash que vous pouvez
retrouver sur rt france bonjour olivier
delamarche merci d'être avec nous cet
après midi sur rt france alors on l'a
dit les allemands avaient déjà refusé
les eurobonds en 2011 comme les français
d'ailleurs à l'époque pour lutter contre
la crise économique pourquoi cette
inflexibilité de la part de berlin alors
que paris lui a changé son fusil
d'épaulé parce que ça sert à rien ça
montre simplement la fébrilité de
certains pays qui sont face à des des
gérants dont notre ministre de
l'économie un et d'autres qui sont dans
une situation compliquée on a pas de
croissance à faire un moment en étant en
récession on a une dette qui enfle 1 et
donc ont paniqué on essaie de de se dire
ah bah on va aller voir nos petits
camarades européens qui eux gèrent mieux
leur pays comme l'autriche ou comme
l'allemagne depuis un bon moment et on
va essayer de faire passer soit 1 euro
bondit à quelques il ya quelques temps
et puis cette fois ci le corps en
abondent
et puis cette fois ci ça va peut-être
marcher parce que comme tout le monde
est touché par le le corps navires us
des fois que ça marcherait sur un
malentendu banon ça marche encore pas
sur un malentendu et on voit justement
toute la solidarité et ce fameux couple
franco-allemand couple qui m'a l'air
quand même en grand divorce depuis
depuis un bout de temps donc voilà tant
mieux on va se dire peut-être que le
coronavirus finira par faire entrer dans
la tête de certains que l'union
européenne n'existe pas est une vaste
blague
pourquoi olivier delamarche préféré le
mécanisme européen de stabilité
moi parce que ils se disent que toute
façon qu'il ne l'utiliseront papus je
crois si vous voulez le problème c'est
que là on est en train de voir
on est en train de voir des gens qui
panique que ce soit les banques
centrales que ce soit les ministres des
différents pays
ils savent pas très bien comment s'en
sortir il se lie vont être face à une
récession comme on en a jamais vu jamais
c'est à dire qu'on n'a jamais eue
même en temps de guerre on n'a jamais eu
des pays complètement à l'arrêt et puis
pas un pays tous les pays
donc évidemment que ça va faire des
dégâts comme on n'arrive même pas à les
imaginer
et là dessus on arrive avec surtout des
pays kinky sont loin d'avoir fait du
gras pendant dix ans si vous laissiez
encore on avait refait du gras si encore
on avait eu des rémunérations en hausse
et c'est que les gens avaient refait de
l'epargne que les sociétés s'était
refait de la trésorerie mais c'est pas
le cas du tout hélas aujourd'hui on se
retrouve complètement démunis parce que
je vous rappelle que depuis 2008 les
états ont pris sur leur dos une bonne
partie des dettes qui était délais
bancaires des dettes privées et donc
aujourd'hui on est à bloc donc ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que on va faire
tous comme les japonais c'est à dire
qu'on va se retrouver tous avec 200 250
% dette par rapport au pib mais on y va
on y va on y va on se on ce chapeau ni
ce que ce soit par les banques centrales
qui se met à tout acheter et à et à
faire tourner la planche à billets comme
on l'a jamais fait tourner jusqu'à
présent et puis avec les gouvernements
qui sont prêts là cette fois ci à faire
des chèques alors c'est des chèques sans
provision malheureusement mais son
déchet quand même à qui mieux mieux le
problème si vous voulez l'escaut ce
qu'on peut voir quand même ce qu'on peut
constater c'est que quand la grèce avait
des problèmes quand l'italie était en
train de faire faillite quand la le
portugal faisait faillite
j'ai pas l'impression que on est sorti
nos chéquier à ce moment là et que ce
soit à carnet ouvert qu'on est sorti des
bd montant pareil donc visiblement le
petit virus fait peur beaucoup plus que
les l'écroulement de l'économie grecque
ou italienne et et là on se met à faire
des chèques n'importe comment c'est à
dire qu'on est vraiment dans une dans
une situation où on fait des chèques
sans provisions on promet des choses
qu'on sera bien incapable de tenir
et voilà donc je pense pas franchement
que la nouvelle soit bonne ça ne
m'étonne pas qu'ils est ressorti ce
vieux nanar de 2,2 euros bond à la sauce
corona et puis mais bon on s'aperçoit
que c'est c'est à chaque fois un refus
de pays qui sont un petit peu plus un
petit peu plus intelligent et qui savent
très bien que toute façon quand on fait
une dette comme ça il va falloir un jour
là remboursés et que ça pose déjà des
problèmes de rembourser et celles qui
sont présentes pour pas s'en remettre
une sur le dos en plus vous avez des
gens qui aujourd'hui sont en train
d'utiliser leur trésorerie pour vivre
pour vivre uniquement donc ça
m'étonnerait beaucoup qui est beaucoup
de
candidat à souscrire à ce genre
d'obligation
merci beaucoup olivier delamarche
d'avoir été avec nous cet après midi sur
rt frange rappelle que vous êtes
économiste membre fondateur d
econoclaste est que nos téléspectateurs
peuvent vous retrouver sur arte france
sur cette chaîne dans l'émission assez
cash merci beaucoup
à bientôt